l'émission que vous regardez en ce
moment rdi économie
c'est notre dernière édition ce soir
après douze votre rendez vous quotidien
pour l'actualité économique va faire
peau neuve à partir de lundi on va se
retrouver à 18 heures heure de l'est
pour une émission qui va durer une heure
qui va s'appeler son économie et qui de
mieux que gérald fillion l'animateur de
l'ancien nouvelle émission pour venir
tout nous dire sur ce nouveau concept
gerald on a de tout savoir bonsoir mais
d'abord j'existe encore parce que ça
fait une éternité qu'on prépare cette
émission là il ya eu des vacances d'été
bien sûr mais on prépare l'émission avec
toute l'équipe depuis depuis plusieurs
jours déjà
on a fait plusieurs émissions des
répétitions dans le vide qu'on n'a pas
diffusé
alors là je grave déclencher de graves
j'ai hâte de me retrouver à l'antenne
également avec le plus bien mais c'est
ça que ça donne voilà c'est ça qu'on
faisait depuis plusieurs jours j'étais
là oui exactement en même temps et donc
on a on est dans le même studio mais
avec des nouvelles rubriques avec des
nouveaux collaborateurs avec un temps
qui différent avec avec d un engagement
qui est toujours celui d'expliquer
l'économie de répondre aux questions du
public parce qu'on ne répondre à
beaucoup de questions depuis le début de
la coved 19 des points de vue également
qu'ils seront entendus par nos
collaborateurs dans ce qu'on va appeler
le ca
le zoom que vous présentez vous serez là
également pour le lit de l'émission les
rubriques mêlez vous de vos affaires le
coût réel changer le monde créé au
canada
je vous lance en grève jusqu'au d'un
temps que vous vous êtes en train de
gonfler les attentes gerald il y aura
beaucoup de nouveaux contenus c'est une
version faut le mentionner dans la
continuité de ce qu'on fait déjà mais
mille fois bonifiés
et et j'y tiens à préciser que cette
émission que vous regarde en ce moment
rdi économie elle s'est déjà bonifié
beaucoup au fil des ans parce que j'ai
une petite surprise pour vous on voit
cela mener au 25 ou 2008 première
mission g rien changé mon aux données
lajus cuse et moi ce soir à rdi en
direct sur l'économie
la caisse de dépôt fait face à une
demande de recours collectif dans le
dossier norbourg listériose mais penly
frappe elle tous les produits fabriqués
à son usine de toronto l'action de
l'entreprise dégringole et congrès
démocrate à denver l'économie au coeur
de la campagne présidentielle américaine
[Musique]
le bras vous fait quoi
ben j'ai d'abord le brun et kiki qui
étaient là
le grain d'image j'espère que j'ai pas
trop changé pas pris une ride de gerald
mais est-ce qu'ils gardent le même
animateur aujourd'hui qui a 12 s'en est
passé des choses en 12 ans non mais on
évolue vous évoluez j'évolue nous
évoluons tous on avance j'espère qu'on
s'améliore aussi on a fait quand même
peu plus de jeu shift pour vous 3 mai
l'émission de rdi économie et même si je
sais pas si je me suis trompé j'ai
calculé 3014 mission de rdi econoline
ces années depuis septembre 2008 et la
beauté de la faire c'est que luce julien
qui était directrice de deux r10 à
l'époque avait eu la bonne idée
quelques semaines avant la crise
l'effondrement de lehman brothers de
créer une émission économique et le
julier avec paul jeunet avec dominique
rajoy qui sont les directrices ici à
l'information ont la bonne idée de créer
cette émission maintenant de 60 minutes
un moment où nous vivons une crise
économique de grande ampleur comme on
n'a pas connu depuis des décennies on le
sent les téléspectateurs ont beaucoup de
questions ont de grandes attentes et
savoir répondre à une partie de leurs 2
or besoin d'ailleurs cette émission la
rdi économie et encore plus avec la
nouvelle émission son économie à partir
de lundi est ce que vous sentez que ça a
aidé à rendre l'information d'actualité
économique plus plus axé ses pour le
grand public vous l'avez constaté ça ben
je les constater au fil du temps on se
le fait dire
et puisqu'on est là depuis douze ans et
depuis trois mille émissions et
puisqu'on nous fait confiance pour
prolonger d'un autre 30 minutes de faire
60 minutes tous les jours c'est que les
gens en demandent et la demande et
l'économie c'est l'offre et la demande
vont offrir plus pour répondre à une
demande qui grandit alors on sens et il
faut quand même aussi dire qu'en période
difficile comme c'est le cas
présentement les gens posent plus de
questions je sais que des gens qui
vivent des angoisses financière
présentement c'est pas facile parce
qu'on ne sait pas combien de temps ça va
durer il faut pas regarder trop
aujourd'hui les projections sur la coved
19 parce que ça nous inquiète davantage
mais on sera là on sera là pour
accompagner comme on l'est déjà
on sera là pour accompagner les gens
d'abord accompagné mettre en contexte et
y aura certainement des événements
marquants dans les prochains mois les
prochaines années parce que c'est une
période de transition une période dont
on va se souvenir longtemps
j'aimerais vous ramener là tu risques
des moments marquants dans les douze
dernières années qui vous ont vraiment
marqué de façon importante
il ya des entrevues il ya des problèmes
techniques il ya des erreurs à l'antenne
nécessairement mais il ya des des
moments carmen qui sont importants quand
on fait des entrevues donc il ya des
moments dans ten qui sont très forts je
peux nommer personne parce que je veux
pas attirer l'attention sur des
personnages en particulier mais il ya
ces moments là qui sont qui sont uniques
et puis bon on continue à faire ce qu'on
aime ça diront les budgets les émissions
spéciales la consommation les uns pour
tout ça ça va rester et vous êtes très
actif parce que je rappelle que vous
avez écrit délai vous êtes aussi dans un
balado question n'était rex qui se
poursuit
évocation leader vous avez plusieurs
projets de front en même temps
exactement
et là vous m'interviewer là je fais et
hardy a souligné c'est la dernière
édition des économies mais la première
fois que gérald est un biréacteur
émission mais on sera ensemble à partir
de lundi andré hahn et vous vous étiez
au matin au cours des dernières années
alors là vous serez dans cette émission
la partie prenant pleinement à cette
émission là donc c'est un bon plaisir ça
fait 16 ans qu'on travaille ensemble qui
on va encore travailler ses ensembles
j'en suis convaincu on est fébrile
gerald on a très hâte à lundi est
d'ailleurs si à remercier tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous suivent depuis
tout ce temps là et je les invite à nous
suivre à à côté de lundi dont je vous le
rappelle rendez-vous son économie à
partir de 18 heures heure de l'est
ça commence donc lundi